- I feel like those guys
are like Sloth from Goonies.
(Emily laughs)
They're like chained
to this weird part.
Jake, Tom do not
come out of here.
(group laughter)
Hey, you guys!
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this
was the last Monday
morning of your life?
- [Gary] Can't believe it's
that time of year already.
Not for me I'm usually three
weeks early and I'll probably
say happy holidays to you
February 29th so be prepared.
Yeah, it's really, you know it's
actually I work every day but
I actually, starting Saturday,
I actually do take two weeks
with my family
so I'm very excited.
How have you been, good?
Good. Sure, makes sense.
Great, well, why
don't we get going?
What can I help you with?
I know that the odds of being a
human being
are 400 trillion to 1
and so it's not very difficult
to get up in the morning when
that's top of mind.
I will always know where
emerging attention is and
I will never ever fear being
a pioneer in setting up shop.
I think, at some level,
I actually think I'm in the
real estate business.
And that's how I built
Wine Library and that's how
I built my brand and that's how
I built VaynerMedia and that's
how I sell books and that's how
everything I do is gonna happen.
Yeah, I'm not scared to lose it
'cause I think I can gain it and
I do think this
interview's a lot of fun.
I think the interview in
11 years after losing it all
and then bringing it all back
would be really fascinating.
I do think battle
scars are attractive.
I do think adversity is,
you know listen,
I like to tell a good story.
I think stories sell and so
you know what's greater than the
climb from little, losing it
all and then climbing back up?
I mean that is the
apex of a story.
I never say quit your
job unless it's
practical, right?
Meaning if you can afford to.
If you are in a place where,
and when I say can you afford
I don't mean how
much money you make.
I mean, you know, like if you're
20 and if you're willing to work
and live in a basement with
three of your buddies and eat
two dollars worth of food a day
then in theory you can if you
choose to say that that's
what makes you happiest, right?
So I would say, look
here's what I will say,
I am absolutely affected heavily
by the 400 trillion to 1 thing.
It's real to me.
I think that people make,
I don't know to be
very honest with you,
I don't know, Ian, how
people if they were practical,
not emotional, not delusional
if they were practical and
understood the 400 trillion
to 1 how they can't be on the
offense, how they can't debate
oh my God I won the
ultimate lottery?
Why don't I maximize
my happiness while
I have my time on Earth?
My '17 goal is to
tighten everything up.
To be better at
everything that's going.
I had a very good year and
the businesses are going well.
My brand and my
content is going very well.
My family is going well.
My health is going well so
I really want to have cut 20% of
the baby fat in all of
those directions and
become more efficient,
more successful
in all those things.
- How are you?
- It's good to seeing you.
- You guys all set?
- [Gary and DRock] Yeah.
- [Samantha] Awesome.
- [Gary] What up, Facebook?
Good morning.
It's me, Gary.
I don't do a lot of Facebook
video direct actually ever.
Anyway, good morning.
iHeartRadio Z 100 Elvis Duran.
All you New York and New Jersey
peeps especially my age know
exactly what I'm talking about.
Tune in right now.
I should be on pretty shortly.
Not exactly sure but
what time is it right now?
- [Other Tyler
and DRock] 8:06.
- [Gary] Hey, morning.
- [Man] Gary!
- [Gary] Hey. I'm gotta tell
them what time I'm going on.
- In five minutes.
- [Gary] Good. Okay.
8:11 in the morning.
Come check me now!
- How are you, Gary?
- [Gary] Good, my friend.
I'm promoting like crazy.
I got all sorts of
people tuning in.
- [Elvis] Fantastic.
- [Gary] How are you?
- We have a bone
to pick with you.
- [Gary] You do?
- Oh, yeah we do.
- [Gary] Oh, good.
- I didn't know.
- I like bones.
- When we leave tell me
what bone we're picking.
- [Gary] I can't wait.
Are we gonna do a
good amount of call in?
- Oh, God yeah.
- That's what I want to do.
- Whatever you want to do.
- It's good to see you.
- You can do whatever
you want to do.
We really have no
plans on this show.
- [Gary] No wonder you've
been successful for so long.
- 'Cause there's no plan.
- [Gary] No, you
know that's real, right?
You know that's
my entire thesis.
- [Elvis] But it's true though.
- That's the way I used to
do tests in high school.
'Member Scantrons?
- [Elvis] Yeah.
- No plan.
B, C, A, B, C.
I'd be done in three minutes.
- [Man] What are you
doing for the holidays?
Saturday, I'm actually
leaving in two days to Florida.
Dropping off our kids and
we're going to Antigua for
five days, Lizzie and I.
Off the grid, phone in safe,
the whole nine.
- [Man] Wait, wait, you're gonna
be off the grid for five days?
- 100%.
(DRock laughs)
- [Man] Is that possible?
- It happens.
It happens.
Every year, that week and then
we come home Christmas Eve and
we spend the next
seven or eight days in
Naples, Florida with my in-laws.
- [Man] That's awesome.
- Yeah, it'll be great.
- [Emily] Samantha's
like he got a latte.
I was like that's a new move.
("Arizona" by Common Souls)
- [Elvis] Gary, it's so
fantastic to have you here
and you had this idea.
Your parents had a
wine store. You took it from a
successful wine store--
- [Gary] Yes.
- [Elvis] into a massive
online wine monster.
- [Gary] That's right.
- [Elvis] Because
you figured out,
and something we
could all figure out,
one little idea can actually be
a massive idea if you actually
do a little work and make
it happen or a lot of work,
make it happen.
- You just beat me
to the punchline.
What I'm scared about is
everybody's driving right now,
everybody's in the
office right now,
everybody's sitting at home
right now and I was listening as
you are prepping me to come in
here and I'm like okay I see how
Elvis is setting this up but
I hope that everybody
understands that the next thing
I'm gonna say is you have to
work until your
eyes are bleeding.
- [Elvis] Hmmm.
- I mean that.
Look, great you have an idea
and yes if you call in now I can
give you four to seven bullet
points that you can dig into
that will probably put you in a
better position to succeed but
I want to make this analogy.
You call in and say
I want to lose weight.
I will give you exactly
what you have to do,
here's the problem.
You have to work out every day.
Here's a good thing 'cause
I always think of this show
'cause I used to listen to it
as a kid growing up
in Jersey driving.
I kind of weirdly want
people to pull over right now.
I realize if you get letters
or calls that people got
into accidents,
that's on you guys.
I'm waiving all my liability.
- Thank you, Gary.
- I want to pull over.
I want you look at that mirror,
rearview mirror that's what
it's called, right?
- [Woman] Yeah.
- Thank you.
I want you to look at it, you
need to understand if you
look at it, it's your fault.
- [Elvis] What do you mean?
- Everything in life is on you.
- [Elvis] Right.
- It's not your dad's
fault who was a drinker.
It's not your boyfriend
that you know cheated on you.
It's not your girlfriend
who's always putting you down.
It is your fundamental fault.
The second you
make that decision
then you can go on the offense.
Do you know, Michael, do you
know the odds of becoming a
human being are?
400 trillion to 1.
Everybody who's
listening if you want to
get real motivated, you want
to become real grateful if you
start realizing that you're more
likely to win the Mega Millions
seven times in your life than
even having a life all of a
sudden you don't waste
three, four years pondering.
Michael, you're
scared of something.
You need to figure that out.
Go make a video right now, post
it and see what happens and if
the world doesn't want
that electronic product
come up with something else.
Thing for me, like I've
already made my thing.
I'm gonna buy the New York Jets
and there'll be a movie and it's
gonna be great.
(group laughter)
At this point, Joe,
this phone call
means the world to me.
You have to
understand why this matters.
If you actually
believe what you just said,
if this is not a fleeting moment
of the energy of this show and
you're able to maintain that
feeling you cannot imagine how
much better your
life is going to be.
- [Elvis] Wow.
So everyone listening
must apply it constantly,
not only today but for
the rest of your life.
Stop complaining and take
control of the things you
actually have control of.
You have more control than you
think you do it's frightening
sometimes but it's true.
- Elvis, Joe, I have to
say this it's the internet.
It gave us options and that's
what eliminated the complaints.
It's the options of the internet
that are practical that
gave us this shot.
We have to milk this opportunity
'cause we're all pioneers
in the early internet.
It's gonna be harder
20, 40 and 60 years from now.
Right now it's practical.
This is our shot.
- We love you, Joe.
Thanks for listening and
GaryVee you're fabulous.
- I love you.
(group cheering)
- You're the best. GaryVee!
(group applause and cheering)
Stop complaining. Excellent.
- That was so awesome.
Like she might literally,
her life may be better.
That's real.
- She--
- She's like wait a minute.
("Intro" by Common Souls)
- [Man 2] Thanks
for your time, Gary.
- [Gary] Thank you.
Take care. Happy Holidays.
- [Man] This is great, Gary.
- [Man 3] Thank you.
- [Woman] Thank
you for coming in.
- [Gary] It was
great to see you.
Thank you so much.
- [Woman 2] Thank you,
thank you.
Have a wonderful vacation.
- [Gary] A girl that
I liked and she liked me,
a junior in high school,--
- [Emily] Yeah.
- she sent me a message saying
I actually do know that
you worked all the time.
(group laughter)
- [Gary] Oh wait,
where's my coat?
- [DRock] We got it.
- [Gary] You got it?
Thank you.
How funny is that?
(indistinct conversations)
This is how it ends.
(Emily laughs)
- [Man 3] This is going to
live on ElvisDuran.com and
we're doing, it's going to
be a quick thing about
New Year's resolutions.
- [Gary] Got it. Okay.
- [Man 3] Start off,
should people make
New Year's resolutions?
- Yes.
- [Man 3] Your answer
is yes I'm assuming.
- I don't know.
- [Man 3] Okay.
- But we're about to find out.
- [Man 3] Yeah.
(group laughter)
- Okay.
- [Man 3] Should people
make New Year's resolutions?
- People should make New Year's
resolutions if they're actually
watching this
video on January 1st.
If they're watching it on
December 23rd they should make
December 23rd resolutions.
Waiting miraculously to when the
calendar flips to start making
your life better is silly at
best and pisses me off at worst.
And so, whenever you're watching
this because it was on the
internet and thus that means
you could watch this on
June 17, 2017 make
a resolution every day
of your life 'cause you
only get one at-bat.
Hope you guys have
a great holiday.
- [Man 3] Yeah.
You too, thank you so much.
- Yeah, real pleasure.
- [Man 4] Thank you.
- Thank you. Take care.
- [Samantha] That was awesome.
- [Gary] I like the snake.
I feel like those guys are
like Sloth from Goonies.
(Emily laughs)
They're like chained
to this weird part.
Jake, Tom do not
come out of here.
(group laughter)
Hey, you guys!
See ya. Thank you.
Yo, am I going to
the airport now?
Just early and
I'll make content there,
might as well. Alright.
Hey guys, it's me, Gary.
Actually perfect.
These guys, this one and this
one just came in here and said
hey, this episode is so iconic
you should chop it up
into three episodes.
So this is not
something I want to do.
I'm blaming these two
characters right here.
And so we're gonna do
this three part episode.
Did you have the audio?
Am I mic'd?
Oh, is that what it is?
-Yep.
- [Gary] Good.
Alright, we'll
see what you think.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)